it's tournament time some college  basketball players do unique things to  get ready for a big game  on game day no matter how much time it  is i always lay down a little bit to get  my mind right  i eat the same thing so it's chicken  some corn some broccoli a baked potato  and i finish it off with some pancakes  my pre-game ritual song is to listen to  march madness by future  because it gets me ready to go battle  i have handshakes with some of the  managers i always have to do them before  the game to make sure everything's  balanced  i always take my rest you know i was  very superstitious about that having my  son's initials on there you have  something to play for you have a meaning  to it and great feeling to look down to  see that  i always put my left sock on before my  right  it's just something i've always done  when i enter the court i always  warm up on the right side of the court  yeah i don't share my secrets  bye